[Captions by Y Translator]
We're crushing our coolest
videos into bite-size pieces
for your inspiration
and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is King of Random Rewind.
10. PVC ALCOHOL CANNON
[Music]
9. STYRO SLICER
8. T-SHIRT CANNON
[Music]
7. PVC CROSSBOW
6. LAMINAR FLOW NOZZLE
[Music]
5. CANDY CANNON
4. SKYBLASTER SLINGSHOT
[Music]
3. ROCKET LAUNCH PAD
2. AK-47 ROCKET RIFLE
[Music]
1. LASER BLOWGUN
Hey guys, Grant here.
Hope you enjoyed
this compilation.
If you'd like to see the full
tutorials for these videos,
we've got links down
in the description.
If you'd like to see
another compilation,
click the box up there,
and if you're
not already subscribed,
then go ahead
and click the bomb.
We'll see in the next video.
Talk to you then.